Hey, what's going on?
It's bill burr and a,
it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday.
And Ah,
what's going on? How are you just checking
on you? You having a good week? Huh?
You getting along with people
and they driving you nuts?
Do you got somebody that
you're not talking to?
I am not talking to that person.
Huh?
What a fucking waste to
energy that you know,
many times in my fucking life I've been
involved with not talking to somebody.
How much fucking effort it takes to not
look at somebody that you're not talking
to in a goddamn room.
You know,
so fucking weird to know somebody.
No,
they were in a room and
not fucking talk to the,
you can't even focus on the person
you're talking to. It's weird.
Cause if they were a complete stranger,
you wouldn't even notice them.
Let's they add a nice rare or
if you're an ass man like me,
they've got a nice ass, you know, you
do that thing where you kind of law,
you know, you look at around him,
like act like you're stretching. Um,
so anyway, so what's going on with you
guys? You know, it's Thursday, Thursday.
Lighten up. Lighten up.
Just, just, just fucking, uh,
you know, smooth out the, uh, the bridges
there. Whenever you build the bridges,
whatever the fuck you say, just walk up
to somebody. Say, listen, you know what?
Aa and I still think you're a cunt,
but I'm still gonna say Elodia cause
I'm sick of not saying hello. So, hey,
how are you? Oh yeah, that's
good guy. Fuck off. No,
you know, just leaving that option
open. Cause it doesn't mean you, you,
you can't cut somebody out
of your fucking life either.
Don't ever be afraid to do that.
Don't ever be afraid to treat
somebody like a fuck tumor. Um,
I don't know why I'm saying all
this shit. Um, I'm actually in a,
I'm in a great fucking mood.
All Billy red face has been
fucking first time in my life.
I've been working in Hollywood
23 years.
I'm working in Hollywood.
Up until now,
all I've done as a random acting gig
and I've done stand up and we all know
that's not working. That's just fun. Um,
the little last week to keep you guys
interested to keep stoking the fires here.
Uh,
me and the guys down at wild west,
the men and women down at wild
west have been editing. Uh,
the six episodes of f is for family
that's coming out on Netflix in December.
And, um, Jesus Christ, dude, Jesus Christ,
um,
all knew I already had respect for fucking
editors and all of that type of shit,
but actually going through
the fucking process, um,
I just just been going all fucking day
long and into the night and all of that
shit. But I gotta tell you this, I am
so ridiculously excited about this show.
I think this might be the one,
this is a, I really got a,
I'm not going to jinx it.
I think I'm,
you guys are going to find it as
funny as we're finding it, but um,
that comes out in December
and uh, I actually, we did
some of the music yesterday.
You wouldn't fucking believe all the
shit you got to do next time you watch
anything. Just listen to
the music, that transition.
Like you got to sit there and watch the
fucking episode and when you go from one
fucking thing that's going on
to another thing, it's like,
do you need like some music there?
If we do,
what kind of music or
this emotion is happening?
What sorta doing that, you know,
I gotta be honest with you,
I love music but doing it that way
it becomes fucking work. But, uh,
I still had a good time cause I'm
the studio that does the music. Um,
they got this one classic song that we're,
that we're going to buy.
You gotta buy the music,
right?
And one of the cool characters
is driving down the street,
not to give anything away here.
And uh,
they let me play the drums over the drum
track to put it on that just to some
fucking cool to do. And
uh, I got to tell you,
it's one of the coolest fucking
things they ever got to do. And, uh,
this guy had a home studio where they
built a room inside of the room and I was
blown away because my whole life, I pick
the fucking instrument we have to go.
Typical fucking comedian, right?
I'm already isolated enough,
already enough of a loner already.
Enough of a psycho. I picked drums. Well,
you basically have to go play in some
studio space in a warehouse in the middle
of some fucking trucking district so
you don't piss off your neighbors and
seeing this person, you know,
personally, I had a house, you know,
with people right on either side,
one of those,
reach out the window and
touch your neighbors house.
And they had built a room within
the fucking room. I mean, Gut,
granted it cost a fortune, but dude,
like you're in there, it's Trump's,
you gotta have your plugs. You go
outside fucking dudes playing. No,
he just said it was cool. It was so
fucking quiet. I couldn't believe it.
So now of course I'm
obsessed with that and uh,
I don't have any room in my house
to do it, but I'm thinking like,
you know this kitchen? Nah. You know, we
don't need to sit down to have breakfast.
I could fucking build a little room
within a room. I could put my fucking,
my drug drums right in there.
Then I'm staring at right now that I
can't fucking play 71 Ludwig green spot.
Right.
Got a fucking kind of play him.
I actually, this is
well fucked up. This is,
I actually have professional carrying
cases for my drums because I have to pack
them up,
put them in the back of my truck and drive
them to a fuck if I want to play them.
I just can't sit down like all you
can to play the Ukulele. Right.
Just sit down and you jam jams and cross
your fucking legs and start singing tip
toe through the tulips, whatever. The
few new with the fucking windows open.
Nobody gives a shit.
Right? It's a Ukulele.
If you get a noise
complaint for a Ukulele,
do you have any idea how bad you suck?
I'm just saying,
all right. The greatest drummer in
the world could be playing drums,
somebody next to those and be like,
know they're going to freak the fuck out.
Um, till it typical. Why?
Why would I pick something so antisocial?
So anyways,
so we've been having a great time and uh,
I got to tell you man,
I think it's a fucking
great God damn show. And um,
everybody,
we got so many people on Sam Rockwell,
Justin Long fucking crushing it on this
thing and it got me laughing and watch
these tapes like 50 fucking times in a
row and they still got me laughing. Um,
uh, I dunno. All right.
Whatever, whatever.
Let's just plow ahead here that Kate has
been a little geek out fucking excited
about this thing. You know I'm loving
about it is Netflix is letting me,
letting us be like standup comedy.
Funny.
Cause they don't have any
fucking advertisers, right?
They don't have them. Well,
when in doubt,
fucking cunts age at 12 to 13 and a half,
aren't you a, you know, fucking uh,
I dunno suggesting that they sniff glue,
whatever the fuck it is that they do.
You know, I don't even know what
they say cause I just glaze over.
I glaze over whenever a meeting and that
happens during a script thing I owe for
my whole career. I just glazed over and
there's just something in my head going,
yeah, yeah, so don't pick it
up. Don't pick it up. Fuck it.
Let's end this business relationship.
Let's get outta here.
I'm gonna go back down to the comedy
club and have a good fucking time.
So we get in this,
this God Damn Romper Room Shit where
you got to babysit adults every fucking
joke you tell whatever. Staying positive
here. Speaking to say in positive,
all Tom Brady,
the manual wall want to be
the life you all want to have.
I got such a kick out of everybody
trying to rub it in that they upheld his
suspension. And by they,
I mean the guy who gave,
who gave out the fucking suspension,
who then was judge and jury. Gee,
did we lose?
Um,
I can't tell you how fucking excited
I am to have a rested pissed off with
something extra to prove Tom Brady
coming in game five. All right.
All you fucking NFL fans out there
who are loving this shit, right?
Cause you don't have a
dimple in your fucking chin.
You don't got a supermodel on your arm.
You know, got a great head of hair.
That's um, but I don't resent
him for it. I'm rooting for,
I'm rooting for, I'm rooting
for his hairline. Um,
deaf fucking guy is going to come
back. I'm telling you right now, he's,
he's just going to fall.
He's going to fucking destroy.
He's never going to
address this thing again.
And he's going to go in there and he's
gonna kick the shit out of people.
And then I just can't wait to see what
the fuck the colts are going to whine
about next year. What are the Raven's
going to whine about next year? What?
What the,
what are they going to whine about those
two upstanding football fucking clubs.
Jesus Christ.
Realize if Robert Kraft had the personal
life of Jim or say it would never be
off at ESPN. I'm telling
you right now, man,
if you want to be a complete the generate,
do it in the fucking Midwest cause
nobody gives a shit. All right?
The press is in New York and they're
new in La and maybe they'll Dell Dell 50
cheap bastards. They'll stop off and
fucking Chicago to get themselves up.
I don't know what a fucking hot dog,
whatever the fuck it is.
You people lead out there.
They don't give a fuck.
Yeah.
If there is no ocean near it,
okay.
There has to be stacks of bodies before
the mainstream press gives a flying
fuck. So if you're a complete piece of
shit, I mean I'm telling you, Indiana,
it's the place to live in
Indiana is the place to live.
If you're in the clan,
you don't even one of the highest
clan memberships in the country.
And what does Hollywood do?
They make these golly, Gee,
aw shucks movie about basketball teams.
Bunch of white people playing
with the fucking globe.
Trotters shorts on even though they're
not on the globe trotters. Right.
I know what I'm talking about. So anyways,
um, uh, I got such exists, one kid wrote,
he goes to employ these
legacies destroyed though.
Is it amongst two?
Huh?
Guys like you who were fucking somebody
else's Jersey and you sit there eating
wings becoming even fatter,
get another chin on your fucking face.
It's destroyed with you.
Do you think he gives a fuck?
His reputation is not destroyed amongst
any of the all time great football
players. That's all it gives a fuck
about. All right. And is that the,
you know what I love about,
he gets his suspension.
There was no proof while you had a bunch
of circumstantial evidence. All right.
And the best you got 'em on is taking
a contest of air out of a ball.
That's all you have,
which is basically watching somebody
had a 500 foot fucking home run,
but they have too much pine tar.
And then you try and be like, well,
if you do know the pie tarp, he wanted
to ground it out to short. What do you,
Oh yeah, we, we won by 38
points. Is that what you're
telling me? Whatever. Enjoy it.
Enjoy it.
You got something to say to a patriots
fan when you fucking lose to us again
next year. All right, so when
join, and as I mentioned before,
I'm totally on board with
dawn Sweeney. Now I got to
be, I'm a Bruins fan. Fuck it.
I've had my little pout. I
love Lou Cheech always. Well,
same thing with Douggie Hamilton,
but what am I going to do?
They're not Brian's anymore.
What am I not watch the fucking Berlin is?
Am I going to start watching Calgary
up there in the fucking saddle dome?
No, I love the king's man, but I'm not
gonna find yet. And I will, you know,
the only good thing about
the Lou Cheech traders,
I got to fucking drive down the
staple center. I can watch them
just sit in the crowd crying.
We miss you man.
So,
but I'm going with this.
This is my obvious prediction with dawn
Sweeney and this is why I love the guy
already.
He is either,
this is going to be either an absolute
fucking debacle or he's going to be
considered an absolute genius.
And I'm telling you,
you gotta respect a man that's
too finally gets this job,
who's got the balls to come in
day one and in the short term,
piss off the fan base,
risking in the end that they're
all going to be loving them,
carrying him down the street
when we went another cup. Um,
he's going all enough and with this and I,
I love it.
So I'm going to sit here and I'm
gonna Watch this Bruins season. Well,
I don't even know if we'll make the
playoffs, but I'm going to watch, um,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna look for the rays of light
is a gradually building this thing up.
And then you try it,
you know,
so fucked up now it's like you literally
have like three years as a GM now to
start with nothing and to somehow
turn it all around and when a cup are,
they fucking shove you off.
But uh,
whatever my fucking hats off to for a,
for dawn Sweeney for having the
fucking balls to do it and um,
that doesn't work out.
I forgive him the fuck you gay.
You somebody got the balls to
do that, you know, I dunno.
What do this is how starved I
am for fucking sports right now.
This time of year,
is it me or does the WNB eight not the
level of play is not nearly as bad as it
was years ago.
And I'm looking at the highlights and it
looks pretty fucking entertaining to me.
I'm just saying an entertaining all right.
I know that they can't jump as
high as the guys and all that shit,
but at the end of the day, I tell
you, I watched that women's World Cup.
It was fucking phenomenal. Very
entertaining. I will watch.
I like women's soccer better than men's
soccer. The women, they get knocked down,
they get back up, they
don't fucking, you know,
rolling around on the ground like the guys
doing the shit they do.
And then when they don't get the yellow
car, the red car, where the fuck it is,
they sit there on their knees.
You know what the eyes all up and
fucking their hands out like this.
Sing in the last few notes in an opera,
the fuck up off the ground.
Jesus Christ,
you are a disgrace.
Anyways.
Um,
does that mean I'm going to go out of
the way to sit down and watch a w and NBA
NBA game? No I won't, but if I'm
flipping through the channels,
I'm not going to shut off.
You'll be great if WMB NBA became this
great thing cause right now they would be
in the fucking ABA years.
You know what I mean?
If I was in broadcasting right now and
I couldn't get in with the big boys,
I'd fucking tried to do a w NBA game.
Try to get in with them the way Bob
Costas has got him with the Aba. Right.
He got in and uh, he became
a made guy. Look at him.
Now it's what you gotta do when
the dinner did Jackie Moon years.
Is that the name of Wheel Ferris
character? I don't fucking know. So, um,
anyways, so they upheld the Tom Brady
thing. Who's kitten? No, off the record.
The guy destroys his cell phone. That's
not a good look. Does it make sense?
This is defense. Makes Sense. Absolutely.
What's Tom Brady going to throw out his
cell phone with a bunch of hall of fame
numbers in there,
you know,
budget models, supermodels, phone.
You can't throw the fucking thing out.
He's got to destroy it.
I would think a lot of famous people
have to destroy their cell phones,
their laptops, everything
before they throw it out. Um,
do I think that, uh, you know, I do.
I think that he knew about
the fucking football thing.
He probably did do I think it's like
this epic level of fucking cheating and
that's why we won. No, not even remotely.
I think it's a little bit of gamesmanship
and I think Jim Irsay is a fucking
baby and that if anybody
did what he did to our team,
you'd find shit that they're doing.
Now.
I know a lot of you guys want
to know only the Patriots cheat
and I don't know what to tell
you. I don't know. You know,
if you can't be honest about your own
fucking team, I'm sure the Patriots Ben,
the fucking rules. But you know, do
you think the buffalo bills don't,
they've never won a Superbowl
Jesus fucking Christ
if,
if you caught them dead to rights.
Okay.
Not just hearsay with Brady. If you cut
the buffalo bill's dead to rights. I mean,
I don't think that you get punished.
They've tried everything else.
They've tried every legitimate
way of fucking winning, right?
They're actually going to be
good this year, man. I think,
I think rex Ryan's going to do real well
with that fucking team because he's a
defensive minded guy, Danny. And he, they,
they already have a great defense and
I think they led the league in sacks
according to this person that I talked
to who was not connected to the NFL in
any way. All right. I think
they're going to do okay. Um,
and you know what?
I bet they play us early on when Brady
is not playing and they're going to win.
And guess who? I'm going to get
a call from all shred and Reagan.
Okay.
I hear from those guys once every six
years because that's how long it takes a
team from buffalo to
beat anybody from Boston
being a country, you know, that's
what I do. Just want to do on here.
A little nice little surf and turf. Little
sugar, little salt. Go Fuck Yourself.
All right, let's read a couple
of advertising here and uh,
I'll try to be a good boy.
They read this shit so I don't get in
fucking trouble again. Well, you know,
like the way you said that big.
So the chickens were cut off.
Well good. So you're fucking chicken in
your A's. All right. Mile Iq, everybody.
Mile Iq.
Yeah.
Smart Miles here, my luck. Cue Driving
for work is a double edge sword,
right? Uh, you don't have to be an
office but your ass falls asleep.
Let me right there. There's your two
sided sword. I never understood that.
Double Edge sword by stabbed some way.
I'm still on the side of the handle.
So how is that a problem? Aren't I
slicing the other guy up a little better?
All right, don't just
read the coffee. Okay. Um,
either you're spending too
much time tracking every
mile or you're guesstimating
and you end up losing money and even
then your estimates falls about 20% short
of what you could be deducting. Stick
it to the mat. Welcomed up Mile Iq,
the gold standard and
map mileage tracking.
You'll never screw yourself over again.
My like he was the only mileage tracker
that detects logs and calculates your
drive for you automatically. You
don't have to worry about it. My,
like who is easy to use and keeps all
your drive securely stored in the iCloud.
If you drive for work and you're
not counting every single mile,
what are you doing? You're burning money
every time you turn on the ignition.
This is a no brainer.
My Lai Q does all the work letting
you focus on what's important,
not hitting a school bus full of kids.
That's why they've got a five star rating
in both the Google play and the iTunes
APP stores. Stop wasting time
manually tracking your miles.
Stop losing money that
you should be redeeming.
Try Mile Iq for free today by texting
bur bur are to this number here.
Eight nine eight zero zero
89 eight Robert Parish,
double zero eight nine eight zero zero
that's bur bur are all caps to your texts
that to eight nine eight zero zero.
All right. Now who do we got next? Oh,
we only got two this week. G whatever
the sales guys, how I forget. Um, zip.
Fucking recruit, zip recruiter, everybody.
Business owners.
Oh this.
Did you know that some of is a
great time to hire the best people?
You know what? I didn't know that.
Is that a good time to hire people?
I figure everybody's laying around.
I don't want to get a job, man.
I want to go to the beach.
With your competitors on vacation
has left less competition for quality
candidates, but posting your job in
one place isn't enough to find them.
So what do you do?
Especially when you're short staffed and
there's no time to deal with the dozens
of different job sites, what can you
do? There was nothing to do until now.
Thanks to zip recruiter.com you can post
to 100 plus job sites with one single
click just post once and within 24 hours.
Just watch all the candidates
roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface plus be instantly
matched to candidates from over 4
million resumes.
Ziprecruiter has been used by over 4,000
businesses and you can try it a try
right now for free.
Try ZipRecruiter and get your perfect
candidate this summer before they go to
somebody else today. You can try
ZipRecruiter for absolutely free.
All you gotta do is go to
ziprecruiter.com/burr that's
ziprecruiter.com/bar high
zip recruiter.com/bar.
That's what I'm doing now when they
make me say it three times, I just, I,
at that point I have to act like somebody
is not paying attention. All right,
what am I speaking to? A
toddler. Um, so anyways,
uh, what else did I want to talk about?
What do I have? Your foot being forced.
Fed. Do you guys see this story?
I didn't really see the story.
What I did was I just looked up Google
news says prisoners on hunger strike in
Israel maybe forced fed under new law.
They're going to do it
like they do to the ducks.
Like stick a funnel in them that Fragua
okay.
I fucking hate that Shit, man. I
fucking it. Why do we have to do that?
How do you force feed a duck? Man? I,
first of all, how do you not like a duck?
I'm not gonna lie to you. I'll
fucking Aye. I duck is delicious.
When I was overseas,
I had this breast of duck that was
fucking outstanding. All right?
But as far as I know, the thing wasn't
forced fed. You know what I mean?
What you want to do with animals is you
let them live a life and then in the end
you take them out like stacks
and fucking a good fellas, right?
You have the duck put on a pot of coffee.
You know what I mean?
He's walking around in his yellow
Skippy's coming up right behind him with a
silencer. Big Bang, done nothing.
They're sticking a funnel on his fucking
mouth. All right? Jillaroos alum,
Joe Rose alone.
This is where Jesus washed his feet.
Joe Russo's alone sticks
on paper in a wall.
Maybe something and visible will
care and make your dreams come true,
but it's your wall.
Shoot.
Anyone else is this. If you had
the love boat in the Middle East,
dig in oil drilling oil,
funneling the money through
the mosque to the Tahoe.
So now be blowing up a pizza parlor.
Alright? Um, Israel.
Less legislator voted Thursday to
allow the force feeding of hunger,
striking prisoners in extreme cases.
By the way, shout out to anybody,
one of those countries.
So who's listened to this fucking thing?
You know who plays drums? You
know, how are you? How are you?
Me Over there. How's it going? Anyways,
a move that appeared to be aiming at
preventing Palestinian inmates from using
fast to when they're
released, particularly from
indefinite incarceration.
All right? There you got to
say, what are they in jail for?
And then you also got to
be like, well, what? Well,
if they want to starve themselves to
death, doesn't that save you money?
Or they become a martyr. They're
already in jail, are already a Marta,
so why don't you just let
them fucking a naughty,
Huh?
It's usually helps when you fucking
read up on these things. This is me.
If I ever did the national news,
I'd wear a suit though.
I would dress up a little,
boop, boop, boop, boop, boop,
boop. Got a black knight.
Leidos, a professional
is that, it's a lie.
I'm bill burr a rides grubs,
cut dab the MOH and the Israeli medical
is though Jason called it torture and
vowed, well wait a minute, it's
torture to force feed somebody.
How do you force feed somebody?
You know what you do is you make like a
fucking peanut butter and jelly sandwich,
but there's no peanut butter cause you
don't want it to be hard to go down.
You wet the bread like
that Asian dude does.
When he wins to a hot dog contest against
all those fucking fat fucks over there
and Coney Island, right? You'll wet down.
It's a jelly sandwich. You ball it up,
may just walk towards, we have a
buyer and you're back. You know,
and then you know, you go,
hey, look at that. When he's
not looking, you get clash.
She Hammond on the nape of his neck
and then you just fucking shove it in.
Very good.
Alright,
most talk about fucking a stamina,
you know what I mean?
If somebody is trying to force feed me.
If I was starving myself,
they came up with a sandwich, you know,
four hours in, I just be like, hey, no,
there's no reason to do that.
I'll eat it.
I wish he didn't dunk it under the water,
but this point has been four hours.
I don't give a fuck. I'll eat it.
All right. Anyways, in recent years,
hundreds of Palestinians and conducted
collective individual hunger strikes.
Let's get to do force feeding.
How the fuck does that work?
You said force feeding. When
not, I thought they just
stuck like an ivy in. Yeah.
Wait a second. Wait a second. Where
the fuck is that? That's the part.
It's absolutely clear that
this is torture. All right.
Wait a minute here. So now,
now what do you think?
I'm going to Google. Huh?
Not going to Google the fucking weather
force. Feeding the fuck
did I get on this subject?
Methods.
Okay.
Oh, Ben, your mouth.
Oh, we'll shove it up. Your
digestive tract force feeding
autonomo force feeding.
Here's what really happens
when you force feed someone.
This is somebody that you
know, who the fuck knows, okay,
this needs to be a wire here and
the medical associations, red cars,
both condemn force feeding, widespread
condemnation. Nobody likes it. All right?
So they stick in a fucking chair that
looks like one of the prototypes for those
weeder. Jim. Thanks. You know, like just
imagine if you work in your upper chest,
so you got to use at a 45 degree angle
and then they got these two like cushion
things so you can't turn your head.
You don't like the neck pillow.
Just imagine if it was
for the side of your face.
They got these two giant
blocks on either side.
Then they strap you in and they will yen
like fucking Hannibal Lecter placement
or they put a feeding tube.
Oh, they shove it up your nose.
No matter the circumstance.
Placing the feeding tube is tricky,
especially when the subject is thrashing
around saying, stop doing that. Uh,
it's also vital doctors
performed this procedure.
Even on willing patients have noted
that the tube can go through the nose,
out of the mouth at which points that
it has to be pulled out and replaced.
The tube can also be,
can go down the wind pipe instead of
the esophagus and forcing food into
someone's lung can cause permanent
pneumonia, a collapsed lung or death.
Why aren't they coughing at
that point? Uh, but blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. Right?
So that's how they do it.
A feeding tube,
starvation and refeeding
soon force feeding.
Is it something that
is done on one ms meal?
A person who is forced fed has often
been starving themselves for days.
There are complications that come with
feeding someone who just stopped eating
entirely,
one of which is called refeeding syndrome.
When a person has started themselves for
days, their body metabolism has shifted.
Shifting it back with a sudden lodge
thing of above bar releases insulin.
All right,
this is basing off,
there's this fucking terrible how we
can't get along to this fucking point that
you actually have to put somebody in a
jail and then they stop eating and then
you got to force feed them
and now cause you give a fuck whether
they live or not. This is just depressing.
We're fucking animals, man. You
know what I mean? We really are.
At the end of the fucking day, half
the shit we do. You know what I mean?
Just watch it.
Watch the discovery Channel One time
when they show monkeys and the horrible
shit that they do to each other.
Now that we're finally past the fact that
we realize fucking chimpanzee can rip
your face off and that they also eat
meat and they eat other monkeys and they
enjoy it slowly killing them.
Very sadistically like the, the,
the fucking parallels to human
beings. It's, it's unbelievable.
We're fucking animals. Fucking animals.
So that's why I don't watch the news.
Why don't talk? How fucking
disgusting was that? All right.
That's 28 minutes everybody.
Sorry for the force feeding thing.
You did get to listen to me sing the love
boat theme about the Middle East. Um,
all right. So anyways, I'm
back to playing hockey,
which I'm psyched about
cause I embarrassed myself
so much when I was up in
Canada and, uh, that's a good move built.
Don't play hockey for a while
and then go play in Canada.
I'm sure you'll match up. Well. Um,
I actually played last Tuesday night,
which is great too for the fucking,
uh, trying to lose the weight here.
I'm down to a buck 78.
All right.
It's supposed to be one 77 by Sunday,
um,
to lose my three pounds for the fucking
week. And once they get to one 77,
then the next one's one 74. And that's
when it starts to get exciting for me.
Right? That's when the, uh, the fuck,
you know what I've learned
about trying to get abs,
especially at my advanced age, is the
top two abs. They're easy, you know,
that's like that chick that would fuck
anybody in the high school. It's just,
you know, it's, if you
don't have the top two abs.
So like I don't know what to talk to you.
I had came fucking talk to you.
All right. The middle ones are
motherfuckers and the last two,
I know you have eight packs,
eight packs of those long fucking ones.
And that's when you got to
show people your pubes. So I'm,
I have no interest in those fucking
things. But those bottom two,
the ones that are basically
the security for your navel,
those two that, that it's
basically, it's fucking impossible.
You know what I mean?
That's like one of those deals where you
gotta be starving yourself and eating a
whole chicken every other hour to keep
your body burning it. This when that,
when the trainers use that thing,
it's basically they use creepy shit.
Like basically your body is eating itself,
you know,
he said they went, they're
fucking Orange Tan. Um,
well it's a looks business. It's all
about looks. Um, all right, this is your,
this is your Monday.
Does your Thursday afternoon fucking
podcast or I don't know what the hell you
guys want from me looking at Bam
30 minutes and to just like that.
Um, I'm actually, you know
what, I'm actually starting
to take drum lessons again.
I had so much fun when I was
up in Montreal and typical me,
I got like 10 fucking things going
on once I'm editing the show,
I'm taking drum lessons and then I also
enrolled in the a that helicopter safety
course because I want to start
getting my cross country miles up.
You know what I mean? Which is basically
anytime you fly like round trip,
I guess 25 miles away from the airport,
something like that,
I don't fucking know what I'm
talking about. Um, but uh,
I just want to have all the emergency
procedures down so I'm gonna learn how to
do that.
Fucking an autorotation ought to take it
all the way down to the fucking ground.
Pick out a spot, bring that fucker all
the way down to the ground and then,
you know what? Then I can fly
around out there. I could feel good,
get myself my 200 hours.
Plus if you have less than 200 hours,
you've got to do an annual review.
And who wants to do that? 200 hours.
It's every two fucking years,
right?
So then I can blow off studying for
23 months instead of the fucking 11.
I'm going to be in the same boat.
What are you going to do? But, uh,
I want to get my hours
up to like 200 hours.
And then I feel like once I have like 200
hours and have really flown around the
La based and I know all the fucking
radio calls, got it down by heart,
I really feel like I
know what I'm doing then.
And only then will I bring up a passenger.
Um, but I'm really excited about it.
And uh, I dunno, I got add,
I have to have at least three
fucking things going on at once.
And then my schedule gets
totally overloaded. And then
I'm like, what the fuck?
And then my wife's like,
you need to relax.
And then I get rid of a couple of things
and I chill for a few days or maybe
even a week. And then it slowly
builds back up again and um, uh,
it's, uh, it's how I do it.
So go fuck. He's not, and I
don't say that on Thursdays.
You know what?
Enjoy your weekend.
[inaudible] you know I have a
good fucking time. Oh, by the way,
I want to learn how to smoke. No
thing I'm trying to do. I've got,
I've got some ribs this weekend.
All right.
Anybody else got the big green egg?
Just tell me how high to pile the fucking
charcoal and then they hickory that I
put in there.
I'm a little confused about that.
Do you always have to soap the hickory?
I know they have the hickory
chips where you're soaking,
but if you get a big block, a hickory
that doesn't need to be smoked. Right.
Just in general. That would, when
it lights, it's, it doesn't burn.
It's smokes. Am I correct in
thinking that cause everything else,
I'm fucking ready to go. I got
the barbecue, I get the rib rack.
I got that Barbecue Guru thing that's
got the fan on the fucking timer.
I got the place I'm ready to go.
And what I want to do is basically just
start doing it fucking like I always
tell how I always learned how to do shit
fucking up royally and making an ass of
myself and then gradually
I get it down. So, um,
I'm interested in doing
that. So if anybody, uh,
if you'd done a pork shoulder on the,
on the egg or if you've done ribs,
just let me know.
Uh,
I'm really interested in how that whole
thing works as far as building that fire
and on how the fuck it
stays lit the whole night.
Like I watched this guy do a,
a pork shoulder with pork,
but more fucking accurate.
And um, he put his, uh,
the things that will lighten the charcoal,
the little squares he put them, he,
the way he did it was he just stuck them
on the left side knowing that they were
going to slowly, they'd light and then
they'd slowly burn all the way across.
And this fucking guy just went to bed
and woke up like eight hours later and he
was still right at the temperature
that he needed to be. And um,
you know what I mean? I'm not the
brightest guy. That fucking blows my mind.
So if you guys know how to do it,
please let me know. Cause, uh,
I want to be one of those guys
making youtube videos going. Oh,
look at that smoke ring.
Oh, alright. So that's it.
That's the Thursday afternoon
podcast. Enjoy the, uh,
the throwback podcast here from,
uh,
a podcast a long time ago from
a time, uh, that was not now.
That was a back then.
That's it. Uh, oh. Hey.
And also I'm a book in my fault.
I got a bunch of fucking dates coming
up that it will be announced, uh,
in one granddaddy of them all. Um, and
I'll be announcing those soon. All right,
so that's it. I gave a little teaser.
Everybody started telling you friends, oh,
red face has a show calledF is for family.
It's coming out on Netflix in
December. And, uh, he's pretty, uh,
he's pretty excited about it and
right be the first to tell people,
well, the watch that show, so you can
be the dude. I called a guy, whatever.
Just do me a solid if you
can. I appreciate it. The
can I understand. All right,
that's good.
Have a good weekend.
Um, all right, so let's get on with the
podcast. Last week, ladies and Gentlemen,
I had the pleasure fear of performing
on the David Letterman show.
And uh,
most of you went out,
you watched it and you all set
me wonderful emails about it.
And I would read you the wonderful emails,
but they're not funny,
but you are in luck.
You know what ones are funny?
The ones where people did
not like my performance.
So let's read a couple of
those, shall we? Um, all right,
let's read the hate mail here.
So what happens with all of all of my
hate mail is when people don't like,
my act is you can't just
write me evidently and just
say that you don't like my
act. You don't appreciate
what it is I do on the stage.
What you have to do first is you have
to establish what an incredible sense of
fucking humor you have and how open you
are to all different forms of humor.
You know, it's that classic thing
like those douchebags on Youtube. Oh,
palm is a fucking idiot
and I'm a Democrat, right?
So then we can be like,
wow,
this guy is left and even he
doesn't like this lefty guy.
So this is what they
do. All right, so here.
So these both these emails follow to a
Goddamn fucking t did the motherfucking u
and v um,
they follow it.
They follow that pattern bill. Just read
the fucking thing. Okay, here we go.
All right. Hi there. How this one
starts. Starts off. Nice enough.
Hi there.
I've been a fan for a while.
You seem to have a unique take
on things. Look at this, Huh?
Pat me on the head.
Let me sniffer hand making
me nice and fucking relaxed.
I loved your bit about the muffins
and the mass vehicular murder.
So there you go.
She just showed how it just her
sense of humor spans the globe,
whether I'm attacking food are actually
running over human beings on the
sidewalk.
She finds it all funny though.
And here's the rub though.
As a stay at home mom,
I now completely despise you.
I did this bit about being a
stay at home mom. Um, so anyways,
she says the hardest part about being
a stay at home mom is being respect is
being disrespected by everyone.
I now hope the worst for you,
despite what funny acts you
may think up in the future.
You are a jerk and deserve the
worst that life has to offer.
Okay?
I don't fuck it. I don't, I
don't understand like these,
this is the classic fucking person
where everything is funny until it comes
around to some shit in her life.
And I make some fun of some shit that
she's doing, being a stay at home mom.
And now all of a sudden she goes from
being a fan of mine to now I am a jerk and
deserve the worst that life has to offer.
That's,
that's a fucking hard courts that you
deserve. The worst that life has to offer.
So what? I'm going to get leprosy, ed, uh,
be constipated all at the
same time and fucking, uh,
survive a plane crash, but
not in a good way, you know?
Anyways, I don't fucking know. Rarely
you're going to take it to that level.
So I wrote her back and
I said a sweetheart.
Oprah Winfrey called your job
the toughest job on the planet,
on national television and got
an applause break of approval.
How much more respect do you need?
I think that's a great point.
If I could step outside the email,
break the fucking fourth wall.
Is that what it is? The third wall? I
never knew what the fuck it was. Huh?
Oprah Winfrey's on TV saying you have
the toughest job on the planet and
everybody claps.
All right.
Did she say being a standup comedian
is the toughest job on the planet?
You think you know what it's like to be
fucking disrespected you apron wherein
sheltered son of a bitch.
Huh?
You want to talk about being disrespected?
Look at fucking comedians anytime
they show a comedian in a movie.
Is it a Chris Rock level comic?
It never is.
It's the fucking hack with the lampshade
on his head going Wakawaka right.
Okay.
Didn't the fucking comedian gets
shot in his gut during Scarface.
Ah,
did a fucking stay at home.
Mom gets shot in the fucking stomach with
that Mr. Potato head mask on her face
during that show. No. You know why?
Cause she was at home taking
care of the fucking kids. Ah,
Jesus Christ jobs can read
the rest of this email.
I didn't even fucking make sense.
It started off funny and then it just
went right off the rails like a Prius that
you can't fucking stop. Um,
anyways, uh, she says, so I wrote,
I wrote how much more respect do you need?
And then I said,
meanwhile there are children
working in sweat shops.
Would you rather be a stay at home
mom or an eight year old sewing Adidas
together for 16 hours a day?
Yeah.
I came up with another great example
that I wish I had used on TV. How about,
how about you work on one
of those fucking oil rigs,
like those poor bastards who work for BP.
Then all of a sudden out of
nowhere the fucking thing explodes.
You standing on a metal structure in
the middle of the goddamn ocean and next
thing you know blows up.
Probably blew up both your air drums.
He had deaf now and you're on fire.
All right?
And your only option is either burning
to death or jumping off of basically the
equivalent of the top of a brownstone
trying to enter the water without doing
the world's biggest flaming belly flop,
right?
You land in the water,
second and third degree
burns in saltwater. Alright,
pus and blood is oozing into the water
and now all you can do is pray to God
that the Coast Guard gets there
before a sea of sharks eat you alive.
Okay?
All right,
you want to do that or you want to
watch Bob the builder for the 800 time
lighten up. And then I wrote, Oh,
and don't despise or
hope the worst for me.
That causes premature aging hugs.
I know that was kind of mean to say,
but you know what? Go Fuck Yourself.
All right. Here's another one. Once again,
we have to establish credibility
at the top of the email.
Are you guys ready for the credibility
to be established? Jesus Christ,
I know I am. Here we go. Ah, Bill,
I am never appalled or capital letters
offended by comedy that I see in here.
All capitals. This sentence,
I have a great sense of humor.
Wow. This is unbelievable. Isn't
that amazing podcast listeners,
this person is never appalled or offended
by comedy that she sees or hears.
She has a great sense of humor.
She has such a great sense of humor.
People that she had to
yell at at me and emails.
All right, so just no way she
had a problem with my apt, right?
Let's read the rest of the
email, however. Oh Gee.
You're a parents on the David
Letterman show that I just watched.
Just put down women and motherhood
to an extent that is just downright
unbelievable. dot.dot. Now she's
going to yell again and tasteless.
Now she yells for the rest of this email,
but I'm going to spare you guys.
All right.
I'm going to read it and soothing tones,
but she's screaming the entire time.
That's what I'm guessing because
it's all capital letters. Um,
this is what she says.
I challenge you to be a single parent
and raise a child and work and attend
college alone without any help just in
case you don't know what being a single
parent meets. All right? Um,
you have no idea how hard it really is.
I am disgusted with your act and
will not ever buy any of your DVDs,
et Cetera.
For the first time in my life,
I am disgusted with comedy.
Your comedy, that is like a, she
starts speaking like in film nor,
and I'm disgusted with this comedy.
Y'All comedy that is say, Eh,
23.
Skidoo alright.
Your Act touched on many topics that you
were disgraceful and very unappealing.
I think she got so mad she stopped writing
sentences. Um, first of all, sweetheart,
I wasn't making fun of a
single, uh, single, uh,
parents that was making fun of
single parents. Nobody would laugh.
I was talking about stay at home moms.
All right.
You don't remember that
line hanging out all day,
making grilled cheese sandwiches.
You given a puppet show,
you dress like a dragon and
then some other adult comes
home and gives you money.
You're like a big kid.
That's some other adults coming home,
giving you money is your fucking husband.
You dumped broad.
Do I gotta fucking spell it out to you?
So I just wrote her back.
I just said I wasn't
talking about single moms.
I was talking about stay at home moms.
You weren't listening
just about the time.
I've actually been talking
about this shit on stage and uh,
I don't give a fuck because
it's such a topical bit.
I don't even know if people are gonna
think it's funny in a month. But, uh,
can we please talk about fucking
Bill O'reilly going on the view?
Um, I gotta I gotta tell
you something right now.
I don't like that guy's politics.
I don't like his face.
He has, he has that
racist face. You know his,
when he gets mad, his
fucking, his face gets pointy.
He just looks evil.
He's just not a pleasant
human being whatsoever,
but I got to tell you,
he fucking destroyed on the view,
you know,
and I,
somewhere in there was a victory for men
because he took on for fucking women.
They were all yelling
and he got two of them to walk
off their own fucking show.
How do you do that?
I as a comedian,
I was embarrassed to,
to stand up Kummete comics just quit,
which is why I'm nominating Joy Bay harbor
and Whoopi Goldberg is Douche bags of
the week. What did you think was going to
ask? Do you think he was going to go? No.
Wait,
don't leave.
That's exactly what the
fuck he wanted you to do.
I was actually hoping at that point that
the other two women were going to leave
and then he could just start hosting
the O'Reilly factor on the view.
That would have been he just totally
100% dominated at the very least,
that segment, because I don't,
I don't watch that fucking show,
but just, he just came on.
First of all, he sits down,
he's got on that shiny fucking Joe
Pesci shoot Joe Pesci Peshy suit.
It's difficult to say Joe Pesci suit and
he's got his fucking leg spread like a
with his ball bag. Hang his
shiny ball bag. He locally
if do you ever see like, uh,
when Kennedy debated Nixon, how,
if you listen to it on the radio,
how everybody said Nixon won.
But if you watched it on TV,
Nixon was all tanned up.
He had his legs crossed,
he looked like a winner and Nixon sat
there with his fucking legs splayed and
cross like underneath the chair.
He looked like a fucking moron.
That's what bill O'Reilly looked like.
And he, he just, he still dominated.
I love when he turned to joy and was
just whatever I, I'm paraphrasing here,
but he was just like,
be quiet and learned
that she had nothing,
a fucking standup comic.
She had nothing.
The whole segment was fucking
hilarious. And when he goes, uh,
another gem of a moment was when he goes,
you know,
a lot of people don't realize this,
but 70% of Americans don't
want a mosque at ground zero.
And Joy goes, she goes, well,
I'd like to see that that
poll or something like an,
as she sang that the crowd is
applauding what bill O'Reilly just said.
So you really don't need to see
the pole at that point. And,
and getting beyond that,
what he really should have said was 70%
of Americans don't realize that they're
not building a mosque
at ground zero still,
that they're actually making a rec room
with a ping pong table and an area to
pray kind of like they have an area to
pray it every fucking airport, you know,
three,
four blocks up the street at a God damn
coat factory is where it's actually
being built.
But the fact that he said that they're
still building a mosque and that he got
an applause break,
joy is so wrapped up into her own fucking
opinion that she doesn't even hear her
own studio audience back up.
The guy that she's trying to shit on and
the fact that this fucking guy is still
putting out inaccurate information,
that people are still back in edit.
It just was fucking awesome
on all of those levels.
And a, I liked how Barbara Walters was
old school. Cool. And she didn't walk off.
She gave those two Douche bags of the
week shit for walking off their own show.
And then she got him with a nice
little classy Zinger. He said,
Bill O'reilly's on here this week. When
we come back, we're going to talk, um,
or he's on the show today. We're
going to, when we come back,
he's going to talk about his new
book called pinheads and Patriots.
And then she looked at bill and
she goes, at this point, I, uh,
I'm not sure which you are, or something
like that. It was a great little zinger,
but she wasn't like judging the guy.
I Dunno if the whole thing was funny
and just how bill O'Reilly is, is,
is viewed as this intolerant person.
And then he comes on the show of a,
I guess mostly liberals,
and then they show absolutely no
tolerance for him and then throw a fucking
temper tantrum and walk off their own
goddamn show. I mean, you can't tell me,
everybody over at at Fox News wasn't
literally jerking off to that moment.
I, Bill O'reilly Bomas became a fucking
rock star in that moment. That was,
that was like a standup comic
moment that he did to two comedians,
which blew my mind.
You know?
And I know I'm always trashing
the odds on this show,
but that really was a chick way of
handling, losing an argument. Like,
I'm just going to get
off up and stormed off.
He is so used to people paying for your
drinks and holding the Goddamn door for
you.
You actually thought that as an adult
that you were just going to walk off the
shell and this was going to be this big
moment. And he was going to be like, oh,
wait a minute,
let me stop.
Ah,
I loved it. He was like, go ahead
and leave. I don't give a fuck.
I'll take over your fucking show.
Um, so anyways, there you go.
Douche bags of the week.
Joe Bay Harbor and Whoopi Goldberg for
walking off your own fucking show when a
shiny suit fucking,
I can't say he's a moron
because he does know.
I mean, I look, he, he, he's very red up
on that. Yeah. I don't know. I'm
too stupid. This is why I wouldn't,
this is right here.
Why I would never engage as much
as I disagree with his opinions.
I don't fucking pay attention
to politics at all. I don't,
I find it frustrating. I find it
to be it just a rigged fucking gay.
I don't give a fuck, you know,
and I, so I would never try to,
as much as I disagree with Bill O'reilly,
I would never go on his show and try
to fucking one up the guy and think I'm
going to, uh, beat the guy in an
argument about politics. It's like he,
he's paying attention to
these politicians the way I,
I give a fuck about football. I'm not
gonna, I'm not gonna win that argument.
I mean,
why don't I bring fucking Roy Jones Jr
rover and start debating him in about
boxing. I know. It's just, it was, uh,
it was fucking hilarious at
the whole thing was just,
it was hilarious and a big,
big fucking victory for that fucking,
I dunno.
I Dunno. It's a stand
up comic. You fucking,
he just tap out. That
was embarrassing. Anyway,
so let's get on with the God
damn podcast for this week. Um,
I kind of liked that you
guys liked that format.
Just getting the Douche bag
or the week out of the way.
Right off the fucking best.
[inaudible]
notice and remind you, you guys
have a haze. Anybody at work?
I used to work in this
warehouse and we were,
we were a bunch of fucking maniacs and
all day long, all we did was break balls.
Uh,
I've told you this shit before because
we were basically mentally smart enough
to work in a warehouse by the time you
went third grade. You know what I mean?
It's supposed to be 10 boxes according to
the packing list. One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine,
10. There you go. One, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10, 11, 12. Sorry,
sesame street, flashback. Um,
okay.
So we used to fuck around all the time
and our manager had no control over us.
You know, we didn't respect him. We
knew he wasn't going to win fire.
We wasn't going to fire us.
He didn't have the goddamn heart.
And at the end of the day
we got a fucking job done.
So he decides that were the problem is,
is that we're all too fucking young.
There's a level of immaturity out there.
Cause we were all in our early twenties
that we, uh, that he should hire.
He hired this 38 year old guy.
Um,
I actually remember his name,
but I'm not going to any,
I don't name names on this
shit. And uh, Jesus Christ,
that fucking guys, almost 60,
he was like 38 and that was
22 fucking years ago. He's 60.
Okay.
What the fuck?
So anyways,
this guy drove a fucking Sky Blue
Chevy cavalier station wagon,
four door, bare bones,
factory fucking rims.
The car was like three years old.
He had 8,000 miles on it.
All right?
And this guy was a Weirdo and
he had these fucking glasses,
these black frame glasses that nobody
wore in the eighties so we immediately
started calling them
woody. We'd be, hey woody,
how many boxes we get over there?
And this guy was just bizarre.
And he'd come home, why call me? What
are you, are you trying to bring me down?
She kept saying,
you're trying to bring me down.
Did I already tell this fucking story?
This sounds oddly familiar to me.
Okay.
So we would just fuck with them.
We would just be like,
okay at four 31 today, everybody just
start going, what do you, what do you,
what do you, what do you, that's
what we would do. He would be
picking orders down in the,
in the warehouse area and we would
all be picking orders with them.
And then out of nowhere
we were just talking
cold water,
top of our fucking lungs.
I know it's fucking as sophomores
but it would fit. And what,
we wouldn't say it to him,
we would just fucking be,
it was really passive aggressive cause
he already talked to management about us
calling him woody. So it's like,
dude, we're not calling you.
Woody would just go on
woody, woody, woody, woody,
woody, look in your vicinity.
So we do the same thing trying to bring
me down. You're trying to beat me down.
So eventually we haze this guy so
much that he fucking quit. All right.
He and his little Chevy Cavalier fucking
four door sky blue bare bone station
wagon drove right out in the back of
my head. I was like, you know what,
I got a bad feeling that mother
fuckers coming back. That's right.
Right around the time when people
first started going postal.
So it wasn't enough that that we
actually drove this guy out of work.
What are they fucking maniacs I worked
with somehow got the guys home phone
number and the following week he still
didn't have a job and he picked up the
phone. He's like, hello.
And there was 10 of us standing
around the phone and we all go,
Ooh.
And I always pictured him slamming the
phone down and then looking up like that
dude in a clockwork work orange when he
realizes the dude who came and fucking
kicked the shit out of him and
he raped his wife, came back. Um,
that's kind of an ugly story.
It, you know, for, you know,
for as much as people sit there and they
talk about this cyber bullying and all
this type of shit and how fucking
horrible it is, which it is obviously,
uh, you know, I don't like how everybody
tries to act like they were a victim.
Well, I mean weren't you a little bit of
both? Cause I know I used to get bullied.
Jesus Christ walking up the street
looking like fucking that kid on the, uh,
the family Griffith.
What the fuck is that
the hell an Andy Griffith. How did
I come up with a family? Griffith.
Ah, my fucking brain is
mush. Um, yeah, people,
you immediately came walking
up the street. My fucking mind.
My hair was orange when I was growing up.
I think I didn't get the shit kicked
out of me, you know? But then, you know,
I got to live with big, bigger.
I got a couple more freckles.
I got got some more confidence and I
just started picking on kids who were a
younger than I was.
So now whenever I see
those God damn stories,
um, I just, I dunno, I,
I see both sides of it. I just see
like, yeah, you shouldn't have fucking
done that, but I don't judge the
bully because I did shit like that.
You guys didn't do shit like that.
That's the theme of this whole
[inaudible].